and
finally new rule if you want to know why
your kids are so bratty entitled and
always asking for your credit card check
their Spotify playlist because the
messages they're hearing are a full 180
from what kids used to hear when they
turned on the radio Cheno Conor will be
in the in memorium re at the Grammys
this Sunday and it would be great if
they quoted what she said when she once
pulled out of the show in protest she
said there is an emphasis in pop music
on materialism and it's not right to
give people the message that they can
fill their emptiness with material
things so how about this year for a new
Grammy category best song where no one
brags about buying a lot of
before 1990 there were like two
songs ever that glorified money money
that's what I
want and Material Girl
well uh here's a short sampling of some
more recent
offerings and that's just the ones that
have money in the
title why does this matter because
nothing molds teenage hearts and Minds
like music and music culture this is
true across Generations when you turn 12
you're done with your parents and start
getting raised by pop
stars the older people have the money
and the power but kids rule the charts
and the lyrics of your youth are burned
into your brain like that time you saw
your father getting out of the
shower
I don't remember I don't remember a lot
from eighth grade don't don't get me on
the formula for the radius of a circle
but if you ask me to finish the lyric
all you need is I'm pretty sure I could
come up with love but if I asked a kid
today to finish that lyric what would
they say I'm not sure but I know what
their Heroes say they say things like
diamonds on my neck I like boarding Jets
but nothing in this world that I like
more than checks
and sure it started in rap but everybody
does it now damn I love the Jag the jet
and the Mansion even country music has
songs like Rolex on a
redneck
really the band Florida Georgia Line has
one about how pimpy their truck
is I don't know but maybe this kind of
unbridled lusting for material thing is
actually the kind of grooming parents
should be worried about we went from so
we don't have a pot but at least I'm
sure of all the things we got to I want
to be a billionaire so
bad kids blame my generation for ruining
the planet but good luck saving it kids
if this is what you're always dreaming
about always hearing a drum beat that
happen happiness results from getting
things things that a vast majority don't
have the pop stars of my youth their
message to me was that what made them
happy was available to me
too even though we ain't got
money I'm so in love with you
honey
yeah I don't need no money I've got all
the riches baby bab one man can claim
Can't Buy Me Love You don't have to
worry if you got no money people on the
river are happy to give the monkeys
saying our Good Times start and end
without dollar one to spend but how much
baby do we really need Kanye says
Lamborghini mercy your chick she's so
thirsty I'm in that two- seat Lambo with
your girl she's trying to jerk me
[Music]
to which the monkey said it was more of
a rhetorical
question John Lennon said imagine no
possessions I wonder if you can and
10,000 rappers said we can't and we
don't want
to and you know
what you know what I don't blame him I
get where this comes from there is a
racial element to this Suburban white
hippie kids had the luxury of being
anti-materialistic because they were
never denied material things in the
first place there's a reason Jimmy
Buffett didn't sing about bling he was
already eating a cheeseburger in
Paradise but the history of black people
in America is the history of being
denied the means and often even the
right to buy stuff including a home in
the neighborhood you might want to live
in so when the long denied finally
becomes available there's going to be
some flaunting if you were excluded from
luxury and then finally got it you
wouldn't want to shut up about it either
but
forever and not just in rap everybody
does
[Music]
it and if and if your answer to that is
okay
Boomer that's that's not an answer and
vomiting an inventory of your
possessions doesn't make you a poet
and
and it's been done to death aren't you
tired of it I'm old this is
old
get a second idea for a
song
well actually there is one
sadness H maybe they're connected yeah
Spotify actually has data on the types
of songs the kids like and it shows that
gen Z's number one search last summer
was
sad artists like Billy ish and Demi
levado have pioneered a whole new genre
called sad Bops a good beat you can
dance to it and then you want to Slit
your
throat I'm just saying maybe they're
connected the good news is I've seen the
music industry clean up its act before
not with sexual assault they're still
doing that
but but at least with the message of the
music which for quite a long time was
dominated with tear jerkers like Slob On
My Knob like corn on the cob
and ain't but hoes and
tricks and you think I won't choke
no it was ugly ugly very sexist
and very homophobic there was Ice te and
Ice q but no ice
capades and we were okay with it until
we weren't and maybe it's time now it's
not to be okay with teaching kids you're
only as good as how much stuff you
have